all right let's take one more let's go
to germany in atlanta georgia jeremy
what's up brother
hey dr d thanks for taking my call i'm
big fan of
you and the whole ramsay team thank you
so much man how can i help today
well i heard you answer a boundary
question the other day
and i wanted your take on our situation
my wife and i
got an email from my brother's wife in
february saying that they were not able
to buy
christmas gifts this year so that they
and they'd like not to receive any from
the rest of the family as well because
of that
and my wife and i are in baby step seven
in a position to bless them
and we'd like to do that so is it
inappropriate of us to go
and get them gifts
i think it would be inappropriate to do
that
just up and do it
if i was in your situation i would
respond to that email
and say thank you so much for letting us
know about your situation
it's been a hard year we're praying for
you let us know we can help
that that honors his honor your
sister-in-law right your brother's wife
right right and then i'd call my brother
and say look
brother to brother here's the situation
i'm in
i would love to bless you guys this year
no strings attached no special this is
and that's
i just had a good year and
honor him in that way if you think he
can hear it
do you think he can hear it or is he
going to roll his eyes and be like
here's my brother trying to get in my
junk again
is you know what i mean i think my
brother would hear it but
his wife maybe would have a different
so he might agree to it and then later
she would regret that he did that's
between
her and him not you okay do you have a
relationship with her do you have a good
relationship
well it's been strained over the years
as we've had kids and they were not able
to and
so it's it's been up and down
um she's opted out of some family
gatherings
when we've gotten together sure um
so the hard thing for you is she's
allowed to do that she's a grown-up
and you're a grown-up and so
i wouldn't take it personally you've had
a lot of wins you've had kids you're a
millionaire
they haven't they've had different
financial situations they've not had
been able to have kids there's all kinds
of dynamics at play here right
right so when it comes down to it
honor her wishes man i do think it's
worth calling your brother
i do think it's worth leaning into him
and saying hey man how can i help and
it's his responsibility to manage his
relationship with his wife if he thinks
that's going to get them too in trouble
and all that
great i also think
this is a great year to not do christmas
presents as a family
to buy each other one cd of
your favorite music to buy each other
one book that's impacted you in the past
year
to buy each other one hilarious coffee
mug or one hilarious shirt
the temptation this year is going to be
to
spend your way out of this funk
to try to compensate for the kids lost
graduations and loss
school events and lost little league
seasons and
lost business opportunities by trying to
buy people
happiness back and good folks it does
not work like that
now jeremy you're in a different
situation man you're a millionaire
for those of you who don't know i work
for dave ramsey baby step 7
is the pinnacle that's when you can live
like no one else
and more importantly give like no one
else
you can give obnoxiously generously
somewhat recklessly
but sometimes your gift is somebody
else's burden
sometimes somebody else doesn't want
that gift and if she drew a boundary
you got to respect it that's the
honorable thing to do
even if you think you know better than
that boundary
so call your brother lean into that but
good folks
every year this same thing happens
christmas just up and surprises us
it surprises us emotionally it surprises
us financially
it surprises us spiritually right
so here's a couple of things i think
i think that every year
i don't know for a thousand years couple
thousand years
again i'm making that up there's going
to be some calendar expert who's going
to write into the show
go for it it's going to make you feel
good and i'll learn something so i say
write in write in with vigor it's
probably wikipedia for crying out loud
but christmas is on december 25th it
just is
in the united states christmas is on
december 25th same time
every year and so it shouldn't surprise
you
it shouldn't sneak up on you and blow
your mind
you can save a hundred bucks a year i
mean i'm sorry 100 bucks a month
and have one thousand two hundred
dollars to spend at christmas
you can spend 50 bucks or you can save
50 bucks a month over the course of a
year and have 600
to spend on christmas whatever it looks
like it doesn't sneak up on you
when it comes to the emotional side of
the relational iq
side who are you going to buy presents
for
where are you going to go what year is
it to go to which
family in this season of a pandemic can
we travel
when you know to somebody's house where
they're gonna have different government
restrictions or somebody else who's
gonna be high risk or
do i work in a job where i might have
coven take it to people
all those things are conversation you
should be having right now
today today
and if there was ever a year to do
something different this is the one
if there's every year to say you know
what we just keep
upping the ante with how many christmas
presents we buy we keep upping the ante
for how
extravagant christmas gets done stop
this is the year of the reset this is
the year when we say
you know what kids we're each going to
get each other two things
three things and then we're gonna go for
a long
christmas walk we're gonna all cook
together we're going to do
things not related to an xbox
not related to a screen we're going to
just be together we're going to figure
out how to play games
my kids this morning and last night but
this morning when i woke up i woke up to
the sounds of them
jabbing at each other and cheering and
talking trash
they've taken that old-school game clue
which a game they don't have any idea
how to play
and created a new kid game version that
really doesn't make a lot of sense
um it's like playing with drunk college
kids
it's not a lot of like rational thought
but the idea is awesome and we sat down
for a game
and it's all great and good and when
everybody loses to the four-year-old
it's hilarious and
but man they are making memories they
are using creativity and they are having
a lot of fun and they are
have developed some sort of weird game
where the rope beats the pipe and the
pipe beats
the whatever the candlestick and so on
and so forth
and now my four-year-old's like the
power hungry mogul in the house right
now
but all that to say decide to have
experiences decide to have engagement
with one another decide to look each
other in the eye
and i also believe this with all of my
heart if you know i'm going to visit
uncle eddie you know we're going to
visit grandma and grandpa
and this is just who they are they are
loud they always
get us crappy food they get frustrated
with us
they never like the gifts we buy and you
choose to still go
you forfeit the right to throw a fit
when you're there
because you knew if you get there and
suddenly you're like uh
my parents are just doing this again you
knew you knew
and so at that point you were choosing
to feel bad
you're choosing you're making a stone
cold decision
to have a less than experience don't do
that
don't do that go into it and make the
best of it go into it with a smile
go into it like jeremy just wants to
bless people good for you man
if it's not going to be your brother and
your wife so be it
find other people to bless i know you
will because that's your heart
and if somebody wants to bless you and
you've had a really humble
crappy year let him bless you
this isn't the year for ego this isn't
the year for being right this is the
year for saying thank you
i'm grateful for you man i'm really
grateful for you
christmas will be here on december 25th
prepare for it now
financially spiritually emotionally
what does the christmas season mean to
you
and just because they changed the color
of a coffee cup is not a political
statement everybody
everybody relax
let's make christmas peaceful let's make
christmas
joyful let's make the holiday season one
that we want to look forward to
and not drama and stress we're done with
drama and stress we've had enough
so i could talk all day about gift
buying and boundaries
and christmas it's my favorite time of
the year
it's when all the leaves are off the
trees everything is stark and bare
and the world slows down we just all
have a little peace